As we get closer day by day to the much overdue
removal of Donald Trump, we have to start
seriously addressing the question of how to
deprogram nearly 75 million Trump.
This is not a trivial matter.
This is not easy to do.
I've said before Trump will go, but the Trump
ists will still be here.
The Trump ism that has become their sort of
guiding.
I don't want to say guiding principles because
it's not very principle, but their guiding
ideology that will be here.
So how do we do it?
How do we deprogram these people?
A retail strategy of convincing individuals
that their views are misguided is just too
time consuming.
I had this caller to my show last week who
said, David, I did it.
I'd programed one Trump.
And I said, well, how long did it take?
And the guy said, it took three hours.
So as you can see, three hours time, 75 million.
That's a problem.
All right.
It's easy and popular to say education's the
solution.
We have to improve education.
Well, we do, but that's not going to help
people already out of school.
There's no doubt that teaching, critical thinking,
media literacy, epistemology starting when
kids are 10, 11, 12, that would preemptively
insulate a lot of Americans from being brought
into these cult mentalities.
But we're talking about seventy five million
people mostly who are already out of school.
So fixing education won't fix them.
So what do you do if you research cults?
You very quickly learn that forcibly removing
people is not recommended.
It rarely works.
You need to get people to a place where they
choose to leave the cult voluntarily.
What we do know is that Socratic methods of
questioning, asking people what attracted
you to the cult, what was going on in your
life when you know you don't want to necessarily
use the word cult here.
But when when you started to say, hey, I think
Trump has something for me, what was going
on in your life?
What attracted you to it?
How would you know if the leader was lying?
What would it mean to you if you realized
that the leader was misleading you?
How would you react?
That type of Socratic interviewing and questioning
can be useful.
But again, we are talking small scale cults
here.
We are dealing with seventy five million people
who are regularly being programed by Fox News
and Rush Limbaugh and the Republican Party
and others, and they're being pulled further
into the cult.
So it's not looking great so far.
One idea is that their beliefs and illusions
have to have consequences that they link to
their beliefs.
And that last part is very key.
Obviously, Trump cultism has led to more coronavirus
deaths than we needed to have.
We have we are worse off as far as health
care goes.
Our foreign policy is is materially worse
because of Trump ism and the Trump cult and
Trump.
So there are consequences to Trump ism.
But your average cultist will never link the
consequences to their cult leader, in this
case, Donald Trump.
So one idea is actually seeing and feeling
the consequences of their beliefs could be
a start.
But how do you do that?
How you do it when we don't even have agreement
about the basic facts is a real problem.
And this, as you can probably tell, is such
an overwhelming Herculean task that it's likely
going to require multiple components and a
sort of full court press approach.
So education.
Yes.
More education for young people, but that
is going to deal with people who are mostly
not yet voters, we need to do something about
current cultists.
Do you have to look at the FCC and look at
what can and should be done from a regulatory
standpoint in terms of media?
Yeah, I guess so.
But I don't think you're going to solve this
problem by banning Fox News and you run into
some real problems with regard to suppression
of speech when you do that.
So I don't know how big of a part that's going
to play.
Another big part of this is we need to make
it less appealing to be part of the cult.
Lots of people get drawn into cults and conspiracy
theories in the first place because they either
find the cults in conspiracies better than
the alternative of the real world or because
people are isolated and they get a feeling
of belonging that's really tough to pull people
out of.
Of part of this is making it less seductive
to be part of the cult while recognizing the
underlying concerns that people have.
And that's what Trump on purpose or accidentally
this is what Trump did do well in 2016 by
tricking people, Trump bamboozled people by
convincing them that he had the solutions
to their problems, a fear that a lot of white
voters had of losing a privileged status in
society.
Trump said he would take care of that immigrants
as the reason that you aren't making more
money.
Trump said he would fix it.
So part of the deprogramming has to be acknowledging
people's concerns, but making them realize
that they've been sold the wrong solutions
are really, really important aspect of this.
And even if we do all of this, we have to
realize that change is slow unless it's a
completely authoritarian dystopia.
If you consider that the start of this cult
that we see today could have been the welfare
queens stories of Ronald Reagan's presidency
35 years ago.
And you understand that this has been 35 years
in the making.
It no longer is reasonable to think we're
going to get out of it very quickly.
It's going to take time.
If you consider the start of the current Republican
cultism to be the civil rights movement of
the 1960s, then, you know, if it took 50 years
to get into the 60 years to get into this
is going to take a while to get out.
One of the faster programmings we've ever
seen or better said, maybe reprograming was
in China during the Cultural Revolution.
Under Mao Zedong, it was a roughly 10 year
period.
The left overs of capitalism were purged and
it was done brutally and quickly and quickly,
still meant a decade.
So what I want people to understand is this
isn't going to happen overnight.
The fastest reprograming have been brutal
and horrifying, like the 10 year Cultural
Revolution in China.
The path will be very long and it typically
requires the type of commitment that two,
four and six year political terms, which is
what we see in the House, White House and
Senate to foreign six years.
That's not a timeline that incentivizes the
difficult work that needs to be done.
So send me your thoughts.
Send me your ideas.
This is going to be a very, very long fight,
which it can start the day we decide it starts.
I believe it has already started to some degree.
Send me your thoughts.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman,